unhealthy advice we do okay go ahead
unhopeful boss with bobby kalila and
theovar
uh nosotros would buy to you you guys
can call me abby
uh here's the quick bobby version uh
before she gives us the full thing i was
molested as a kid now and i'm grown
should i tell my family what happened
some details for contacts i was molested
as a kid by my next door neighbor and
yes fat kids also get molested it
happened when i was five to seven years
old i am now 24 years old my family
never knew about it and stopped after we
moved
i need some help that i'm 24 and moved
on with my life and process all that
junk i have a hob a hubby and a dog and
i'm in my second year of law school and
i love it it's a very nice life i'm a
little [ __ ] up on the inside maybe
that's why i love tiger belly so much my
family still doesn't know and sometimes
it feels like they don't understand a
huge portion of the struggle that made
me into the woman i am today
they are super big bible thumping
christians uh sometimes i don't fit in
with them lol help this molested kid out
so
essentially she wants to tell her family
i've been niddled a lot yeah
i um i i had an instance with a black
man that touched my penis one time how
old are you and
he was 22 remember and sometimes people
were like your race is like i didn't i
wasn't upset at the guy because he was
black you know what i'm saying yeah yeah
i would have said that the guy touched
my penis outside
you know at a par at not a party where a
kid swimming in this like
big like um
bucket basically a pool and no a bucket
yeah yeah yeah i wouldn't call it a pool
man
i appreciate the [ __ ] yeah yeah let's
try it
yeah i appreciate you trying to have
that for me yeah yeah hypothetically and
imaginatively but i know it was it was a
large it was a cistern or whatever you
know
it was part of something maybe the top
was sharp the top was sharp i see you
could have somebody kind of lift you in
and out and this guy just kept lifting
us and just [ __ ] overlifting us yeah
it was like dude you're lifting us by
our dick you know yeah
like it's getting weird but uh but it
wasn't like something real sick anyway
this isn't about me this is about
somebody who wrote into the show well i
mean this my aunt used to do this
in korean you go
go
you know i mean pull your dick she would
say yeah and it'd be like five male
cousins
and my brother and i
and we pull our dick and she would like
like just tickle it
oh yeah it should be giggling
right we wouldn't get aroused but i
always found it weird that is weird yeah
i mean yeah like and i would be i would
do it because you know what i mean
here's what i'll say
in regards
i think you've just told us you're on
dittle d cause guys your penis is this
fun buddy it's like my buddy yeah it's
your buddy yeah um brace yourself for
double the disappointment because when i
confronted my family about not having my
back when an older family member
molested me
i didn't get the reaction that i wanted
and it kind of
made me spiral even more because i'm
like oh what was the point of even
attempting to open up with them and i
would have i would be forced into this
situation with my abuser and i'd have to
spend christmas with him and everyone's
just like come on it's christmas like
just let it all go and i'm like i love
christmas i i know my favorite but so i
would say manage your expectations i
don't don't
i love it i love it too you stop bro i
love it too he's making handsome i know
i'm not you [ __ ] i love
christmas man yeah
yeah we'll talk about that later i like
christmas carols too i love christmas
carols yeah caroling is still a thing in
the philippines so it's a feel-good
thing uh-huh just don't don't do it in
the house sometimes one time they came
into the house can we carol
we should go caroling can we finish her
advice for the trauma i know i'm just
saying though when the carolers come
into the house like we didn't invite
them in they opened it and they just
walked in we didn't say come on in you
know that's weird
burglary okay
oh that is oh start taking something
they didn't sing or anything they just
took our vcos so what happened at
christmas i'm sorry we interrupted i'm
telling this girl manage your
expectations yeah
you might feel like you're you know
especially if they're like bible
thumpers and stuff they might feel the
need to just sweep it under the rug so
just don't expect too much but
maybe just
you know
yeah find some way to forgive if you can
in some way i don't know i i don't know
i it didn't hap
you know whoever molested you didn't
molest me so that's your you know more
about it than i do i shouldn't give any
suggestions but
um
i think i think saying it to your
parents without any expectations get it
off yeah just to give them the
information just to give them context
this way without expecting anything back
yeah yeah cause a lot of people are fr i
know a lot of people fry on their own
fish right now man i think a lot of
people are just stuck thinking about
what did what does my life mean is there
the rat race what's going on should i
live in a city should i live in the
woods what is what does society mean
what are we doing like i think a lot of
things feel confusing to people mm-hmm
um did you kill yeah happy birthday text
did i seen a happy birthday text i did a
voice memo oh yeah you did
thank you man i sent you a nice one and
then it got at the end got a little
weird and so i deleted that one and sent
you a second one honestly i like that i
liked it i remember thank you yeah you
said nice you said something nice i
wanted to be at your party man that'd be
that would have been great are you in
town for a while or no
um nope i'm leaving tomorrow going where
i'm going in that i got some tour dates
i'm doing touring right now okay give me
the tour dates some on the weekends
where i don't even know where they are
wilk's bar